[Musique]
monsieur Éric fidol bonjour bonjour Je
vous interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle sinkerview
j'aurais aimé avoir votre qualité
d'expertise sur les récentes fuites de
prisme sur les fites que
différents entreprises différents
organismes organisent vous laisse faire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
c'est un vaste débat en fait pris
d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
c'est que c'est pas la la comment
s'appelle la première le premier cas en
fait prisme c'est juste un un
sous-programme particulier d'un plan
plus général autrefois ça s'appelait ça
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans le un
programme que l'on connais qui s'appelle
échelon qui dont un des sous-programme
était
euh carnivore
ouais il faut savoir que le contrôle de
la technologies passe par le contrôle
des acteurs qui mettent en uvre cette
technologie donc c'est même plus fort
que ça c'est pas que c'est les sociétés
qui ont été incriminé et d'ailleurs il
manque certaines sociétés euh et laisser
fuiter ou et laisser sortir des données
c'est tout simplement c'est une
obligation de pour les sociétés
américaines de travailler avec l'État et
en particulier les services de
renseignement américain c'est c'est un
autre monde hein c'est pas c'est très
éloigné de la vision européenne mais euh
c'est une d'AB on oublie que a cette
obligation VI du
Patriot qui est une loi qui est cert a
été créée par Bush junior mais dont les
derni les plus récents développements
ont été signés validés par
Obama l'Embar de l'administration
actuelle c'est que elle ne pouvait pas
pas
savoir ce sont des plans concertés
organisés pour leô des technologies
quelles sont les les répercussions pour
le citoyen français ah bah pour le
citoyen français et pour les le citoyen
européen je dirais B c'est simple c'est
que je dirais queelles sont peut-être
préoccupantes pour le citoyen lambda
elles le sont plus pour les entreprises
françaises dès lors qu'on utilise un
service comme Facebook comme qu'on
utilise Google comme moteur de recherche
qu'on utilise un système d'exploitation
bien connu qu'on utilise un iPhone de
toute façon les données que l'on met
dedans et encore une fois il y a pas que
des données personnelles aussi des
données d'entreprise ces données faut
considérer qu'elles sont lues à livre
ouvert vous parlez de facebook qu'est-ce
que vous avez découvert sur facebook
quelles sont les répercussions de
Facebook sur la vie privée des gens plus
en détail alors déjà d'un point de vue
général il faut savoir que facebook je
trouve que c'est un
un un un superbe succès on a réussi à
faire la plus grande agence de
renseignement privé au
monde ça c'est quand même prodigieux et
où les gens li leur propres données
volontairement donc déjà ça c'est génial
et c'est vrai alors on a découvert un
Combre de choses on n pas tout découvert
c'est que euh on en parti dans le
domaine de la téléphonie mobile quand on
se connecte sur facebook l'application
facebook euh elle récupère à l'insu de
l'utilisateur des tas de données qu'elle
dissimule sur téléphone alors elle les
dissimule pas tant que ça parce qu'elles
ne sont pas chiffrées mais elles sont
stockées en gros l'application Facebook
sur Android se comporte comme une
véritable éponge on sait des d'autres
hackurs l'ont révélé que quand Facebook
prétend vous confirmez qu'il a bien
effacé vos données en réalité ces
données sont toujours présente il y a
une petite expérience simple à faire
supprimz votre profil Facebook supprimer
votre compte Facebook il suffit d'aller
sur une baninière de connexion de
remettre les anciens identifiants et
comme par magie votre page réapparaît ça
veut dire que tout est stocké tout est
stocké on St pas les choses sans but en
réalité il faut voir Facebook comm une
la plus gigantesque
je veux dire organisme de de
renseignement qui jamais été fait c'est
la stasie à la puissance ce que l'on
veut
quoi qui qui en France quel organisme en
France peut protéger les gens qui peut
protéger les entreprises queles sont les
dispositions entreprises par l'état
français pour nous protéger entreprise
et nous protéger citoyens alors
normalement on a la c la Commission
Nationale Informatique et Liberté le
problème c'est qu'elle n'a pas ses
pouvoirs sont limités et sont de plus en
plus reniés notamment par les
dispositions de l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce par le lobbying extrêmement
intensif des multinational qui font
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile pour
la laacil et les organismes similaires
en Europe de bah de mettre ses grandes
compagnies au pas on a vu toute la
difficulté qu'il y a qu'il y a eu euh
pour contraindre Google à modifier
notamment les règles soi-disant de
protection de la vie privée les
Allemands étaient moins inefficaces que
les français c'est un problème de moyen
mais aussi de volonté politique
euh alors après euh la protection ben
c'est pas un problème technique déjà on
est libre de ne pas utiliser d'utiliser
Facebook ou pas donc je pense qu'il y a
un problème d'éducation il y a un
problème de rendre les utilisateurs
comment s'appelle conscient des risques
mais je pense qu'il y a aussi un rôle
des politiques d'interdire certaines
pratiques et de euh d'obliger à
certaines à certaines disposi de
sécurité alors en fait le problème plus
général c'est quand on estend une
entreprise le problème n'est pas
tellement la technologie c'est le droit
dont elle dépend il y a une différence
fondamental en droit euh européens et
français euh pour lequel bah les données
que l'on confi à un prestataire euh vous
Contin continuent d'être votre propriété
ça veut dire que le prestataire a une
obligation ou à minimal moyen pour
protéger vos données alors qu'en gros
anglo-saxon les données appartiennent à
ceux qui les traitent alors un
journaliste dont j'ai oublie nom avait
une formule subtile euh chez Google euh
le produit i c'est vous donc dès lors
que vous soumettez vos données à lui
appartiennent il est libre d'en faire ce
qu'il veut de les donner à qui il veut
de les exploiter commercialement et ça
c'est une différence fondamentale je
dirais que la première règle pour une
entreprise c'est d'ailleur de regarder
parmi les différents prestataires qui
s'ofr qui s'offr à elle de regarder de
quel droit C ce prestataire ou cette
compagnie dépend alors c'est difficile
parce que quand on est une
multinationale une grande société
française ben faut regarder si par
exemple le capital il y a pas des fonds
de pension américains si la société bien
dépend bien de droit français ça devient
de plus en plus complexe et c'est pour
ça que je conseillerais à des aux
sociétés PME PMI de favoriser plutôt une
offre on parle beaucoup du cloud ou du
de l'hébergement externalisé bah de
prendre plutôt des petits des acteurs
régionaux qui vont offrir une
garantie quant au au dispositions de
sécurité pris sur les données que qui
leur sont confi vous avez parlé des des
politiques des
législateurs qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur leur formation sont-ils
prêts sont-ils suffisamment formés pour
appréhender correctement les risques que
le numérique comporte est-ce que vous
pensez que ces mêmes
législateurs sont trop soumis à des
groupes de pression est-ce que ces
législateurs sont tout à fait intègres
est-ce que c'est est-ce que les
législateurs vont dans le sens de
l'intérêt
général vaste question en fait il a
plusieurs aspects d'abord il faut savoir
que de par par en France en tout cas la
formation des hommes politiques est
inadaptée à l'évolution du monde
technologique nous avons des gens qui
ont fait souvent le ce qu'on appelle
leur humanité ça une formation plus
droit histoire du droit éventuellement
pour les les moins littéraires économie
mais on a on se retrouve en situation où
nous avons des décideurs qui ne
comprennent plus rien à la technologie
et qui prennent des décisions
malheureusement qui impactent nos vies
faut sair que l'informatique les les
technologies de l'information et la
sécurité qui va avec maintenant concerne
nos vies quand on va à l'hôpital quand
on déclare nos impôts bref dans les
moindres fait et
gestes et ça c'est important de le
savoir donc nous avons des hommes
politiques qui ne comprennent plus la
technologie si tantit qu'il l' jamais
compris un jour alors c'est pas gênant
dans l'absolu parce qu'on peut pas être
spécialiste en tout ça veut dire que
comme c'est le cas dans certains pays je
pense en particulier à l'Allemagne qui a
su effectivement capitaliser sur sa sa
sa communauté de vqueur ça veut dire
qu'il faut être bien entouré il faut
avoir des
conseillers qui effectivement ont un
sens de l'État et je pense que depuis le
général de Gaulle ce sens s beaucoup
perdu on a des lobbyistes alors je suis
désolé le lobbyiste le lobbying est un
terme est un terme on va dire
politiquement correct en Afrique ça on
appelle souvent de la corruption
euh il faut quand même quand on voit
comment certains marchés publics
notamment récemment on été violés
euh bon après c'est un problème de
sémantique on peut on peut dire mais ça
quand même ça ressemble à ce que l'on
critique chez d'autres le problème
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
revenir à une certaine idée de l'état à
une certaine intégrité et indépendance à
une certaine force de caractère pour que
nos hommes politiques soient entourés
des bons conseillers alors ça touche un
autre aspect c'est la sélection de nos
élites
euh le problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
représenter l'ensemble de la nation
uniquement avec une petite fraction
sortie seulement de quelques écoles le
retard qu'à la France comparé par
exemple à l' Allemagne qui de ce point
de vuel a été très très pragmatique
c'est que la France est en train de se
couper de toute une fraction importante
de la population d'une extrêmement
grande qualité al qu'on a coutume
d'appeler les hackurs al en France le
problème c'est que le mot haur est est
diabolisé on oublie simplement que ce
sont des gens qui privilégient les
résultats sur les méthodes et qui sont
capables de gagner une connaissance
intime d'un système ce sont pas du tout
les acteurs malveillants qu'on veut que
l'on que l'on déc confond d'ailleurs
souvent avec le mot pirate ce qui veut
dire que ces gens-là sont diabolisés
sont complètement écarté du débat alors
qu'il pourrait contribuer on parle
beaucoup de réserve citoyenne mais si
c'est pour le faire uniquement avec des
polytechniciens des normaliens des
Centraliens on va pas aller très loin je
pense qu'il faut toutes les bonnes
volontés sont à prendre il faut plus
regarder chez un jeune ce qu'il peut
apporter à l'État et non pas ce qu'il a
fait entre 20 et 24 ans et là je suis
sûr que la France sera un pays qui
redeviendra une nation de tout premier
plan il faut quand même oublier qu'il y
a un génie français et pas seulement en
sorti de nos grandes écoles moi j'ai
coutume de dire à mes étudiants que on
est un un mélange subtil et aussi un peu
aberrent de d'écart et d'esprit Gaulois
euh on le voit dans la communauté des
hackurs Français on a la chance en
France d'avoir une communauté très vive
très innovante malheureusement une bonne
partie d'entre elle par aux États-Unis
fa même savoir que beaucoup de hackurs
il soit junior security hacker ou senior
seccurity hackur chez Google Microsoft
Apple ORAC novel sont des Français et ça
c'est quand même dommage vous parlez de
Microsoft qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur les contrats qui ont été passés
par la
défense on va dire qu' il ne respecte
pas pas franchement disons la règle en
matière de marché public et que c'est
pas la transparence qui a qui a prévalu
mais je veux dire là maintenant tous les
documents ont été publié et qui prouve
qu'effectivement il y a peut-être un
certain ménage et certaines pratiques je
veux dire à à à revoir maintenant il
faut savoir que la France a fait le
choix de revenir de manière très très
importante et totale dans l'OT temp l'OT
temp a POS ses règles et quand je dis il
impose ses règles impose surtout les
produits américains donc c'est très
délicat pour nos hommes politiques et
malhe nous n'avons plus de général de
Gaul depuis très longtemps c'est très
délicat de faire marche arrière en tout
cas de réaffirmer une certaine
souveraineté mais en tout cas on n'aura
pas de sécurité si on ne passe pas par
ça vous parlez de certaines pratiques
lors du passage de certains contrats
avec la défense est-ce que vous pouvez
développer disons que le lobbying est
disons
des des règles
particulières s'applique alors que le
marché le marché public
les règles du marché public devent
s'appliquer on a vu tous les documents
on a vu qu'effectivement c'était pas la
transparence en particulier en France il
y a une obligation quand vous passer un
marché c'est de
toujours prendre en priorité l'offre
logiciel libre quand elle est quand elle
est présente quand elle se présente
encore faut-il la susciter or dans le
cas
présent lors du passage du marché on n'a
pas on s'est pas assuré qu'il y aurait
des gens venant du logiciel libre qui
pourrai proposer une alternative que
sont devenus ces personnes qui ont signé
ces contrats avec
Microsoft alors on va élargir un peu le
débat mais en France il y a une r qui
veut que tout hautfonctionnaire
militaire ou non quand il quitte
l'administration a obligation de ne pas
travailler pendant 5 ans dans
l'entreprise avec laquelle il a
travaillé étant fonctionnaire je
laisserai
les les personnes qui regardent cette
vidéo faire une petite recherche et
regarder où V certains de nos ha
fonctionnaires par qu'ils sont recrutés
et on verra que c'est une règle qui est
malheureusement régulièrement bafouée le
devoir de réserve ah c'est plus que le
dévoir de réserve le devvoir de réserve
s'applique quand on est en poste donc le
délai de carence c'est ce que c'est un
délai de carence c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un délai ù on va dire je sais
pas si c'est une clause de non
concurrence ou en fait il y a obligation
de ne pas travailler dans un domaine où
avec dans une société avec lequel on a
passé des contrats très bien un dernier
mot
qu'est-ce que vous nous qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire votre votre
perception sur les whistleblowers Julian
Assange Jeremy
amondadle manings alors je pense que bon
Aron Schwarz je pense que ces gens-l ont
un rôle positif d'un autre côté ça me
dérange parce que si vous voulez c'est
quand même le triste spectacle que
d'abord il faut savoir que l'information
vient le plus souvent et d'origine
interne alors certes on pourra toujours
dire que ils ont révélé des choses qu'il
était bon alors qu'il était bon en tout
cas qui intéressait et qui mettait à
jour certains faits maintenant ils l'ont
livré de manière peut-être dans certains
cas irresponsable en tout cas ça
témoigne d' d'un malaise et d'une
délicessence de la société vous faites
le parallèle avec Vladimir Vetrov
laaffaire farwell ce Russe lassé de
cette hiérarchie corrompue qui a fait
fuiter des renseignements sauf que je
mettrai pas la même chose je mettrai pas
sur le même plan PHEL l'a fait au risque
de vie et il l'a fait en sachant qu'il
resterait anonyme il l'a fait parce que
je pense que c'est un idéaliste pour
autant je le sache effectivement je
pense qu'il était c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement était est peut-être
dégoûté de certaines pratiques où avait
compris que le monde allait changer on
ne peut pas nier le fait que pas
certains de ces whistleblowers ont un
certain ego et il est difficile de
savoir quelles sont leurs motivations
réelles moi je trouve préoccupant quand
même qu'une société parce que les
whistleb il peut y en avoir dans la
société française moi je pense que c'est
illustre plus le fait que bah les
notions de loyauté les notions de
fidélité ou disons c'est une forme de
vol quand on prend des données qui ne
sont pas à soi qu'on les met dans la
place publique sans hors de tout
contexte ça pose quand même des
problèmes mais je pense que c'est le
révélatoire d'une fer qu'on est une
société de plus en plus malade ù c'est
le règne de l'argent le règne de la
puissance et voilà c'est juste un
révélateur donc après bah c'est qu' révé
les assang je qu' révé les Snowden
effectivement c'est intéressant
maintenant ça ne sera pas 100 poser les
problèmes de disons de sécurité
nationale et
internationale je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être effectivement mettre en place
un certain nombre de de mécanisme pour
que les whistlebowers puissent le faire
mais que ce soit quand même je pas dire
contrôler parce que leot protéger
législativement parlant les whle blowers
oui mais ça existe déjà pour
l'administration fiscale c'est un
problème de là on favorise vraiment des
gens qui à mon sens alors je peux me
tromper mais agissent quand même
beaucoup par éego agissent de manière
assez souvent irresponsable parce que on
oublie
que l'affaire Wikileaks a quand même
jeter en pâure des noms propres des gens
qui étaient des serviteurs de leur état
alors on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
l'État américain mais ce sont des gens
qui ont un idéal et qui servent qui
servent leur patrie et je pense que on a
on n pas le droit de le faire de cette
manière là prisme a été précédé par un
programme qui s'appelait stellar
wind qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'un
programme secret qui est capable de
faire un mapping intégral d'une
population d'une entreprise sur les
habitudes de consommation les habitude
de comportement d'une population est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une une façon
que l'État exemp par une crise
financière a pu trouver pour prendre la
température de sa population et pouvoir
encadrer de futur ou de potentiels
mouvement de
rébellion vous parle de Google Google
c'est ce qu'il fait je veux dire il a
des outils comme collusion qui montrent
que dès qu'on fait la moindre recherche
de toute façon on est déjà mappé et
qu'on reçoit des tas de trucs alors
après il est vrai que il y a deux
tendances intéressante c'est que on se
préoccupe beaucoup al on parle beaucoup
du Big Data mais ça c'est le disons le
terme marketing d'un truc qu'on connaît
depuis longtemps qui s'appelle le data
mining qui recherche effectivement des
grosses tendances ce qui est
effectivement clair ce qui est
intéressant dans la question c'est que
ces techniqu là s'intéresse maintenant
moins aux grandes tendances que ce qu'on
appelle les signaux faibles les signaux
précurseurs et en ce qu' dat on appelle
les la recherche d'outler
effectivement alors je serais très
étonné que des projets comme ça n'existe
pas maintenant sont secret son et tout
enfin je veux dire je dirais qu'à la
limite n'importe quel décideur et homme
politique je dirais que s'il le faisait
pas il serait inconscient et incompétent
après faut voir dans quelles conditions
c'est fait dans quel but et autre mais
il est vrai que ces techniques là sont
très intéressantes et d'ailleurs ça
nécessite la collecte d'énormément de
données on l'a vu beaucoup de
bouleversement stratégiques
géostratégiqu on on peut parler des
révolutions 2.0 on peut pas regarde ce
qui se passe dans le monde beaucoup
n'ont pas été forcément prévu peut-être
parce que ces plans là n'étaient pas
encore actifs on s'aperçoit al c'est
toujours facile à postériori de de dire
bah si on avait fait ça et ça on
l'aurait vu il est clair
qu'effectivement ça va devenir si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas une orientation
technologique de tout très très
importante en tout cas de tout premier
plan qui peut se révéler
dangereuse après c'est effectivement si
le signal faible c'est la préparation
d'attentat tout le monde se félicitera
qu'on puisse les identifier les
identifier et les et les parer parce que
le citoyen quiconque a une famille veut
être protégé si maintenant il s'agit de
d'anticiper des mouvements
contestataires vous savez un résistant
c'est un terroriste qui a pas réussi
hein euh dans certains pays on appelle
résistant onappelle terroriste c'est
juste un problème de sémantique et de de
référentiel voilà pour l'instant vous
savez les en Syrie bah si vous demandez
à Bachar alAssad sont dangere terroriste
la perception n'est pas du tout la même
est-ce que vous avez une préconisation
un conseil pour les générations qui nous
écoutent les générations peut-être futur
de hackur qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur
laisser comme
conseil je CIS c'est de garder l'esprit
ouvert et l'esprit humble et surtout de
d'essayer de ne pas lutter aussi de ne
pas céder au sirènes technologiqu on
parle beaucoup de prisme on oublie une
chose c'est qu'on a le droit on a le
pouvoir de ne pas utiliser Facebook de
ne pas utiliser Google il y a des
alternatives il y a un très beau site
d'Urs qui s'appelle
prisme-break.org qui pour chaque
logiciel et technologie qui est
apparenté à prisme donne assez souvent
d'ailleurs l'alternative dans le monde
du logiciel libre voilà il faut
simplement que je pense qu'il faut
éduquer les populations et les jeunes
font partie de son font partie des gens
qui éduqueront plus tard donc il faut
qu'ils soit ouvert aux autres il faut
s'assurer de transmettre la connaissance
la connaissance ne peut pas être une une
Drée commerciale commercialisable et il
faut bah tout simplement exercer son
droit de citoyen il y aura on aura soit
de la liberté soit de la sécurité mais
on aura pas eu de Monsieur Filiol
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'exception
culturelle comment ça a été amené est-ce
qu'on a oublié certaines choses dans
l'exception culturelle
française je pense qu'on peut avoir une
culture libre que quand on a déjà je
veux dire de la sécurité et je trouve
anormal que dans les accords de libre
échange on n'est pas inclus à côté des
la fameuse exception culturelle qu'on
n'est pas inclus prioritairement les
produits de sécurité euh ce que font
déjà les États-Unis il est interdit aux
États-Unis de s'équiper s'agissant de
sécurité de produits non nationaux
violant d'ailleurs par ailleurs l'ordre
les accords de libre échange je pense
que ça devrait être obligatoire de
rendre les produits de sécurité les
technologies de sécurité une chose
essentiellement nationale et donc de la
faire figurer aux listes des exclusions
des accords de libre
échange